[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
audio check one two
final audio checks for the press audio
check one
more
two
[Music]
30
seconds 30 seconds
ladies and gentlemen the first lady of
the united states accompanied by the
second gentleman of the united states
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states accompanied by the
vice president of the united states and
judge katanji brown jackson
so
good morning good morning
[Applause]
good morning america
have a seat please
president joe biden
first lady dr jill biden second
gentleman douglas emhoff
members of congress
members of the cabinet
members of our administration
and friends and fellow americans
today is indeed a wonderful day
[Applause]
as we gather to celebrate the
confirmation of the next justice
of the united states supreme court
judge katanji brown jackson
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
president george washington
once referred to america
as a great
experiment a nation founded
on the previously untested belief
that the people
we the people
could form a more perfect union
and that belief
has pushed our nation forward
for generations
and it is that belief
that we reaffirmed yesterday
through the confirmation
of the first black woman to the united
states supreme court
and judge jackson
you will inspire
generations
of leaders
they will watch
your confirmation hearings and read your
decisions
in the years to come
the court
will answer
fundamental questions
about who we are
and what kind of country
we live in
will we
expand opportunity or restrict it
will we
strengthen the foundations of our great
democracy
or let them crumble
will we move forward
or backward
the young leaders of our nation will
learn
from the experience the judgment the
wisdom
that you
judge jackson will apply in every case
that comes before you and they will see
for the first time
four women sitting on that court at one
time
[Applause]
says as a point of personal privilege i
will share with you jackson that when i
presided
over the senate confirmation vote
yesterday
while i was sitting there
i drafted a note
to my goddaughter
and i told her
that i felt such a deep sense
of pride
and joy
and about what this moment
means
for our nation
and for her future
and i will tell you her braids are just
a little longer than yours
but as i wrote to her
i told her what i knew this would mean
for her life
and all that she has in terms of
potential
so indeed the road
toward our more perfect union
is not always straight
and it is not always smooth
but sometimes it leads to a day like
today
a day
that reminds us what is possible
what is possible when progress is made
and that the journey
well it will always be worth it
so let us not forget that as we
celebrate this day
we are also here
in great part
because of when president joe biden
and
[Laughter]
[Music]
and because of joe biden's vision
and leadership
and commitment
a lifelong commitment
to building a better america
and of course we are also here because
of the voices and the support of so many
others
many of whom
are in this audience today
and with that it is now my extreme and
great honor to introduce our president
joe biden
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you kamala thank you thank you
thank you
the first really smart decision i've
made in this administration
my name is joe biden please sit down i'm
jill's husband
and naomi by his grandfather
and uh folks uh
now yesterday uh this is not only a
sunny day i mean it's from the bottom of
my heart
this is gonna let so much shine sun
shine on so many
young women so many young black men so
many minorities
that it's real
it's real
we're going to look back nothing to do
with me we're going to look back and see
this as a moment of real change
in american history
i was on the phone this morning jesse
with president ramaphosa south africa
and he was talking about how the time
that i was so outspoken about what was
going on and my meeting with nelson
mandela here
and i said you know
i said i'm shortly going to go out look
i'm looking out the window i'm going to
go out on this but they call the south
lawn in the white house
and i'm going to introduce to the world
to the world the first african-american
woman out of over 200
judges on the supreme court
and he said to me he said
keep it up
keep it up
we're going to keep it up
and folks
yesterday we all witnessed a truly
historic moment
presided over by the vice president
there are moments that people go back in
history and they're literally historic
consequential fundamental shifts
in american policy
today
we're joined by the first lady the
second gentleman and members of the
cabinet
senate majority leader
there you are chuck senate majority
leader
and so many who made this possible
but and today is a good day a day that
history is going to remember
and in the years to come they're going
to be proud what we did and we're going
to try what dick durbin did as the
chairman of the committee
[Applause]
i'm serious dick
i'm deadly earnest when i say that
to turn our children and grandchildren
to say i was there
i was there that's this is one of those
moments in my view
my fellow americans today i'm honored to
officially introduce to you the next
associate justice supreme court united
states tonji brown jackson
[Applause]
after more than 20 hours of questioning
at her hearing
in nearly a hundred meetings she made
herself available to every single
senator who wanted to speak to her and
spoke for more than just a few minutes
answer their questions in private as
well as before the committee we all saw
the kind of justice shall be
fair and impartial
thoughtful careful precise
brilliant
a brilliant legal mind with deep
knowledge of the law
and the judicial temperament which was
equally important in my view
that's calm and in command
and a humility
that allows so many americans to see
themselves in catanji
brown jackson
that brings a rare combination of
expertise and qualifications to the
court
a federal judge
who has served on the second most
powerful court in america
behind the supreme court
a former federal public defender
but
[Music]
[Applause]
but the ability to explain complicated
issues in the law in ways everybody all
people can understand
a new perspective
when i made the commitment to nominate a
black woman to the supreme court
i could see this day
i literally could see this day because i
thought about it for a long long time
as jill and nobody will tell you i
wasn't going to run again but when i
decided to run this was one of the first
decisions i made
i could see it i could see it as a day
of hope
a day of promise a day of progress
a day when once again the moral arc of
the universe says barack used to quote
all the time bends a little more toward
justice
i knew it wouldn't be easy
but i knew the person i nominated will
be put through a painful and difficult
confirmation process
but i have to tell you
what judge jackson was put through
was well beyond that
there was verbal abuse the anger
the constant interruptions
the most vile baseless assertions and
accusations
in the face of it all
judge jackson showed the incredible
character and integrity she possesses
poise
poison composure
patience and restraint
and yes perseverance and even joy
even joy
catanji or i can't i'm not going to be
calling that in public anymore judge
you are
the very definition of what we irish
refer to as dignity
you have enormous dignity
and it communicates to people it's
contagious
and it matters it matters a lot
maybe that's not surprising if you look
to uh sat behind her during those
hearings
her husband dr patrick jackson and his
family patrick stand up man
stand up
talia and layla stand up i know it's
embarrassing to girls
i'm going to tell you what talia said i
said to tell you it's hard
being the daughter or the son of a
famous person i said imagine what's like
being president he said she said she may
be
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i couldn't agree more
thank you thank you thank you thank you
and kataj her brother a former police
officer and a veteran so i stand up man
it's the man looks like he can still
play buddy
he's got biceps about as big as my
calves
thank you bud
thank you thank you thank you and of
course
her parents
johnny and elray brown johnny stand up
[Applause]
i'll tell you what
i told mom
mom's rule of my house
oh you're not think i'm kidding i'm not
my mom and my wife as well
look
people of deep faith
the deep love of family and country
that's what you represent
who know firsthand
mom and dad
the indignity of jim crow
inhumanity
of legal segregation
and you had overcome so much in their
own lives
you saw the strength
of parents the strength of a daughter
that is just worth celebrating
i can't get over mom and dad you know i
mean
what what you did
in your faith and never given up any
hope
for both that wonderful son you had and
your daughter
you know when that strength lifted up
millions of americans
who watched you judge jackson especially
women and women of color
who have had to run the gauntlet
in their own lives
so many of my cabinet members are women
women of color
women that represent every sector of the
community
and it matters
and you stood up for them as well
they know it everybody out there every
woman out there everyone am i correct
just like they have
just like they have
the same with the women members of
congress as well across the board
look
it's a powerful thing
when people can see themselves in others
think about that what's the most
powerful thing i bet every one of you
can go back and think of a time in your
life
where there was a teacher a family
member a neighbor somebody
somebody who made you believe
that you could be whatever you wanted to
be
it's a powerful powerful powerful notion
that's one of the reasons i believe so
strongly that we needed a court that
looks like america
not just the supreme court
that's why i'm proud to say with a great
help with dick durbin
i've nominated more black women judges
of federal appeal courts than all
previous presidents combined
combined
that's why i'm proud that kamala harris
is our vice president of the united
states
a brilliant lawyer
the attorney general of the state of
california
former member of the senate judiciary
committee
kamala was invaluable during this entire
process
and chuck the majority i want to thank
you pal
you did a massive job of keeping the
caucus together getting his vote across
the finish line in a timely and historic
manner
just watching on television yesterday
watching when the vote was taken and the
democratic side the great people there
was such enthusiasm
genuine you can tell when it's real
you can tell when it's real
did an incredible job chuck thank you so
much
because you're all able to sit down and
off the stand i'm going to go on a
little longer here and tell you
[Laughter]
i want to say something about dick
durbin again dick i'm telling you
overseeing the hearing how you executed
the strategy
by the hour every day to keep the
committee together and you have a very
divided committee with some of the most
conservative members of the senate on
that committee
it was especially difficult
with an evenly divided senate
dick i served as chairman of that
committee for a number of years before i
had this job in the job of vice
president
as did
all the democrats you did not stand i
think all the democrats on the committee
did
and every democrat in the senate all of
whom voted for judge jackson and
notwithstanding the harassment of the
tax
in the hearings i always believed that
the bipartisan vote was possible
and i hope i don't get him in trouble
i mean sincerely but i want to thank
three republicans who voted for judge
jackson
senator collins is a woman of integrity
senator mikowski the same way in alaska
and up for re-election
and mitt romney whose dad stood up
like he did his dad stood up and made
these decisions on civil rights
they deserve enormous credit for setting
aside partnership and making it
carefully considered judgment
based on the judge's character
qualifications independence and i truly
admire
the respect diligence and hard work they
demonstrated in the course of the
process as someone who's overseen and
they tell me more supreme court
nominations as anyone who's alive today
i believe that respect for the process
is important
and that's why it was so important to me
to meet the constitutional requirement
to seek the advice
and the consent of the senate the advice
beforehand and the consent
judge jackson
started the nominating process with a
prayer an impressive range of support
from the fop
to the civil rights leaders even
republican appointed judges came forward
in fact judge jackson was introduced to
the hearing by judge thomas griffin
distinguished retired judge appointed by
george w bush she finished the hearing
with among the highest levels of support
of the american people of any nomination
in recent memory
so soon
judge jackson will join the united
states supreme court and like every
justice the decision she makes will
impact on the lives of america
for a lot longer in many cases than any
laws we all make
but the truth is
she's already impacting the lives of so
many americans
during the hearing
dick spoke about a custodial worker who
works the night shift at the capitol
her name is verona clemens verona where
are you
stand up verona i wanted to see
you don't mind
she told him what this nomination meant
to her
so he invited ms clemens to attend the
hearing because she wanted to see hear
and stand by judge jackson thank you
verona
thank you thank you thank you
at a meeting with judge jackson senator
duckworth introduced her to 11 year old
is it vivian
vevin
vivian i'm sorry vivian
there's that's her is that your sister
he's pointing
who's so inspired by the hearing she
wants to be a supreme court justice when
she grows up
god love you stand up honey
am i gonna embarrass you if i just ask
you to stand up
come on stan
there's tens of thousands of beings all
through the entire united states
she met judge jackson
and saw her future
means you're here today and thank you
for coming honey i know i embarrassed
you by introducing you but thank you
people of every generation of every race
of every background felt this moment and
they feel it now
they feel a sense of pride and hope and
belonging and believing and knowing the
promise america includes everybody
all of us
that's the american experiment
justice breyer talked about it when he
came to the white house in january to
announce his retirement from the court
he used to technically work with me when
i was on the judiciary committee
and that's before he became injustice
he's a man of great integrity we're
going to miss justice breyer he's a
patriot an extraordinary public service
and a great justice supreme court
and folks
let me close what i've long said
america is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
i was going to put him
excuse me the foothills of the himalayas
with xi jinping
traveling with him i guess we've
traveled 17 000 miles on his vice
president i don't know that for a fact
and uh
we were sitting alone i had an
interpreter and he had an interpreter
he looked at me and all seriously said
can you define america for me
and i said what many of you heard me say
for a long time i said yes i can in one
word
possibilities
possibilities
that in america everyone should be able
to go as far as their hard work and god
give them talent will take them and
possibilities we're the only ones that's
why we're viewed as the ugly americans
we think anything's possible
and the
idea that a young girl
who was dissuaded from even thinking you
should apply to harvard law school
don't raise your hopes so high
well i don't know who told you that but
i like to go back and invite her to the
supreme court she can see the interior
look
even the supreme court of the united
states of america
now folks
it's my honor and it truly is an honor
i've been looking forward to for a while
to introduce you
the next associate justin united states
supreme court
the honorable katanji brown jackson
thank you
thank you all
[Applause]
thank you all very much
thank you
thank you so much mr president
it is
the greatest honor of my life to be here
with you at this moment
standing before
my wonderful family
many of my close friends
your distinguished
staff and guests
and the american people
over these past few weeks you've heard a
lot from me and about me
so i hope to use this time primarily to
do something that i have not had
sufficient time to do
which is to extend my heartfelt thanks
to the many many people
who have helped me
as part of this incredible journey
i have quite a few people to thank and
and as i'm sure you can imagine
in this moment it is hard to find the
words to express
the depth of my gratitude
first as always
i have to give thanks to god for
delivering me as promised
and for sustaining me throughout this
nomination and confirmation process as i
said at the outset
i have come this far
by faith
and i know that i am truly blessed
to the many people who have lifted me up
in prayer since the nomination thank you
i am very grateful
thank you as well mr president
for believing in me
and for honoring me
with this extraordinary chance to serve
our country
thank you also madam vice president
for your wise counsel and steady
guidance
and thank you to the first lady and the
second gentleman
for the care and warmth that you've
shown me and my family
i would also like to extend
my thanks to each
member of the senate
you have fulfilled the important
constitutional role of providing advice
and consent
under the leadership of majority leader
schumer
and i'm
especially grateful for the work of the
members of the senate judiciary
committee
under chairman durbin's skillful
leadership
as you may have heard during the
confirmation process i had the distinct
honor of having 95 personal meetings
with 97 sitting senators
and we had substantive and engaging
conversations about my approach to
judging and about the role of judges in
the constitutional system we all love
as a brief aside i will note that these
are subjects about which i care deeply
i have dedicated my career to public
service
because i love this country
and our constitution
and the rights that make us free
i also understand from my many years of
practice as a legal advocate as a trial
judge and as a judge on a court of
appeals
that part of the genius
of the constitutional framework of the
united states is its design
and that the framers entrusted the
judicial branch with the crucial
but limited role
i've also spent the better part of the
past decade
hearing thousands of cases and writing
hundreds of opinions
and in every instance i have done my
level best to stay in my lane
and to reach a result that is consistent
with my understanding of the law and
with the obligation
to rule independently
without fear or favor
i am humbled and honored to continue in
this fashion as an associate justice of
the supreme court of the united states
working with brilliant colleagues
supporting and defending the
constitution
instead fastly upholding the rule of law
but today at this podium my mission is
far more modest i'm simply here to give
my heartfelt thanks to the categories of
folks who are largely responsible for me
being here at this moment
first of course there is my family
mom and dad thank you not only for
traveling back here on what seems like a
moment's notice
but for everything you've done and
continue to do for me
my brother kataj is here as well you've
always been an inspiration to me as a
model of public service and bravery and
i thank you for that
i love you all very much
to my in-laws pamela and gardner jackson
who are here today and my sisters-in-law
and brothers-in-law william and dana
gardy and natalie thank you for your
love and support
to my daughters talia and layla i bet
you never thought you'd get to skip
school by spending a day at the white
house
this is all pretty exciting for me as
well but nothing has brought me greater
joy than being your mother
i love you very much
patrick thank you for everything you've
done
for me over these past 25 years of our
marriage
you've done everything to support
and encourage me and it is you
who've made this moment possible
yours
your steadfast love gave me the courage
to move in this direction i i don't know
that i believed you when you said that i
could do this but now i do
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and for that i'm forever grateful
in the family category let me also
briefly mention the huge extended family
both patrick's and my own who are
watching this from all over the country
in the world thank you for supporting me
i hope to be able to connect with you
personally in the coming weeks and
months
moving on briefly to the second category
of people that want special recognition
those who provided invaluable support to
me professionally in the decades prior
to my nomination and the many many
friends i have been privileged to make
throughout my life and career
now i know that everyone who finds
professional success thinks they have
the best mentors but i truly do
i had three inspiring jurists for whom i
had the privilege of clerking judge
patty saris judge bruce celia and of
course
justice stephen breyer
each of them is an exceptional public
servant and i could not have had better
role models for thoughtfulness integrity
honor and principle
both by word and deed
my clerkship with justice breyer in
particular was an extraordinary gift and
one for which i've only become more
grateful
with each passing year
justice breyer's commitment to an
independent impartial judiciary
is unflagging
and for him the rule of law is not
merely a duty it is his passion
i am daunted by the prospect of having
to follow in his footsteps and i would
count myself lucky indeed
to be able to do so with even the
smallest amount
of his wisdom
grace
and joy
the exceptional mentorship of the judges
for whom i clerked has proven especially
significant for me during this past
decade of my service as a federal judge
and of course that service itself has
been a unique opportunity for that i
must also thank president obama who put
his faith in me by nominating me to my
first judicial role
on the federal district court
this brings me to my colleagues and
staff of the federal district court in
washington dc and the dc circuit thank
you for everything i am deeply grateful
for your wisdom and your battle-tested
friendship through the years
i also want to extend a special thanks
to all of my law clerks many of whom are
here today
who have carved out time and space to
accompany me on this professional
journey
i'm especially grateful to jennifer
gruda who has been by my side since
nearly the outset of my time on the
bench and as promised
has promised not to leave me as we take
this last big step
[Music]
to the many other friends that i have
had the great good fortune to have made
throughout the years
from my neighborhood growing up from
miami palmetto senior high school and
especially the debate
team from my days at harvard college
where i met my indie fatigable and
beloved roommates lisa fairfax nina
coleman simmons and antoinette sweet
square coakley they are truly my sisters
to my time at harvard law school and the
many professional experiences that i've
been blessed to have since graduation
thank you
i have too many friends to name but
please know how much you've meant to me
and how much i have appreciated the
smiles the hugs and the many atta girls
that have propelled me
forward to this day
finally i'd like to give special thanks
to the white house staff and the special
assistants who provided invaluable
assistance in helping me to navigate the
confirmation process
my trusted sherpa
senator doug jones was an absolute
godsend
[Applause]
he was an absolute godsend he's not only
the best storyteller you'd ever want to
meet
but also unbelievably popular on the
hill which helped a lot
i'm also standing here today in no small
part due to the hard work of the
brilliant folks who interact with the
legislature and other stakeholders on
behalf of the white house including
louisa terrell rima doden tonah boyd
manian moore ben lebault
and
andrew bates
i am also particularly grateful for the
awe-inspiring leadership
of white house counsel dana remus
[Applause]
of paige herwig where's paige
and ron claim
they led an extraordinarily talented
team of white house staffers in the
herculean effort that was required to
ensure that i was well prepared for the
rigors of this process and in record
time
thank you all
thank you as well to the many many
kind-hearted people from all over this
country and around the world who have
reached out to me directly in recent
weeks
with messages of support
i have spent years toiling away in the
relative solitude of my chambers with
just my law clerks in isolation
so it's been somewhat overwhelming in a
good way
to recently be flooded with thousands of
notes and cards and photos
expressing just how much this moment
means
to so many people
the notes that i've received from
children
are particularly cute and especially
meaningful because more than anything
they speak directly
to the hope
and promise
of america
it has taken
232 years and
115
prior appointments
for a black woman
to be selected to serve on the supreme
court of the united states
but we've made it
[Applause]
we've made it all of us all of us
and
and our children
are telling me
that they see now more than ever
that here in america
anything is possible
they also tell me
that i'm a role model which i take
both as an opportunity and as a huge
responsibility
i am feeling up to the task primarily
because i know that i am not alone
i am standing on the shoulders of my own
role models
generations of americans who
never had anything close to this kind of
opportunity
but who got up
every day
and went to work
believing in the promise of america
showing others through their
determination and yes their perseverance
that
good
good things can be done in this great
country
from my grandparents on both sides
who had only a grade school education
but instilled in my parents the
importance of learning
to my parents who went to racially
segregated schools growing up
and were the first in their families to
have the chance to go to college
i am also
ever buoyed by the leadership of
generations past who helped to light the
way
dr martin luther king jr
justice thurgood marshall and my
personal heroine judge constance baker
motley
they and so many others did the heavy
lifting that made this day possible
and for all of the talk of this historic
nomination and now confirmation i think
of them
as the true path-breakers i am just the
very lucky first inheritor
of the dream
of liberty and justice for all
to be sure i have worked hard to get to
this point in my career and i have now
achieved something far beyond anything
my grandparents could have possibly ever
imagined
but no one
does this on their own
the path was cleared for me
so that i might rise to this occasion
and in the poetic words of dr maya
angelou
i do so now
while
bringing the gifts
my ancestors gave
i
i am the dream and the hope
of the slave
[Applause]
so
so as i take on this new role
i strongly believe that this is a moment
in which all americans can take great
pride
we have come a long way toward
perfecting
our union
in my family it took just one generation
to go from segregation to the supreme
court of the united states
[Applause]
and it is an honor
the honor of a lifetime for me to have
this chance to join the court
to promote the rule of law at the
highest level
and to do my part
to carry our shared
project of democracy and equal justice
under law forward
into the future
thank you again mr president and members
of the senate for this incredible honor
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]